father was a high official
very religious man
we were six children
four boys my sister was the oldest i was
the youngest
we did not hear much
because by this time the hungarian press
most likely was
sanjir we listened to the
british the bbc and we knew that there
were concentration camps
but since some miraculous way we thought
we we are never going to go there
it's impossible we had refugees
from poland polish jews who told us
do something go go to dm
go to america go to israel go to
palestine
do something escape
because that's what's going to happen to
you and we thought that's impossible
i mean my father was born here his
father was born here
and my great-grandfather's
was born here it's impossible but we
didn't know enough had we known enough i
think we would have done more
of course when the germans came in
uh we had to wear the uh
the yellow sign you know the star the
star of david
my father had a very elegant
beard which he had to shave
he had a non-jewish
barber he wouldn't shave it
i can't say that all gentiles were
against us
i won't say that they didn't help us
they were passive maybe they were scared
our best neighbors the day
that we have been deported came in
to our house our best neighbor
and i recall it's the first time in my
life i got two pair of new shoes
because in europe you don't buy two pair
of shoes not in our family you bought
one pair of new shoes
but i don't know why i bought two pair
of shoes
and she knew about it maybe i told her
four weeks before and just before we
were
just looking around what to take with us
we were deported she came and she said
where are your shoes
you don't need it anyhow
and it wasn't even painful at this point
who cared
who really cared we were not
defended by our gentile friends by no
means
they didn't do any harm to us
i have to be honest about it
i used to stand at the american
consulate
sometimes like eight to ten hours
had we gotten a visa we would have all
been saved
and made good citizens in this country
and so the day came
we had terrible days
of fear that each time a german soldier
has gotten drunk he might knock on the
door and you have to open the door
but it didn't happen they they broke
windows
they broke doors
but from physical harm we were spared
um one day my father came home
and said we just had a
a a conference with one of the
german office ss officers and he told us
and within three days we have to leave
this town and we have to go into a brick
factory
and we are going to be leaving for
germany
and my father had still his mother was
89 years old or 90 years old
my father being a very clever
person said to him i can understand that
you are going to take us to work i'm 62
years old i still can work my daughter
can work my wife can work
what do you want from my mother how can
she work
she's a sick woman why do you tell me
you're going to take her to germany
and he was the german was clever too he
said you know from our experience
um we know that families
the young will work much better
if the families are there we know you
jews
you stick together and if you know the
grandmother grandfather is there you'll
work much better and much harder
i don't think my father has ever
believed it never
but he never talked about it and in
three days we had to leave
everything that my father worked for 36
years
and that's no tragedy trust me that's no
tragedy
because you can build up a new empire
for yourself
it is that this was the last time that
our family was together
and my sister
her two children my brother-in-law my
mother my father and i
moved into the um
to that brick factory and we stayed
there for two weeks
lived like animals really like animals
and this was just a transition to get
them out from their own homes
put them into the brick factory which
was near the railroad station
and then they took us from the brick
factory to the railroad station
90 people in each
box what now is this this was
june 1944
we didn't know where we had each of us
had just a little bundle
with food that's what they told us to
take
90 people would you talk nine oh
children old people
young ones it was hot
there was no air i still see my
mother sitting there
in the corner with my sister
i'm going to say i'm so warm i'm so hot
i have no air
and today i couldn't understand it maybe
i wasn't that warm
but i today i understand what she went
through not only because there was no
air
but anguish what has happened to her six
children
and maybe that's what made her choke
today as a mother i can understand it my
father did not speak for three days
but my sister
before we arrived to auschwitz i
remember my sister told him
father
we have always been a very god loving
people how come that god has
forsaken us
i remember that very vividly
she in her anguish and my father said
you know we have forsake him before
and i'm so happy about that that i heard
it
because my father was such a devout
religious man that he believed really
that he left god before
god has left him that he went and died
not in vain maybe i don't know
before we arrived to auschwitz maybe a
few miles
we were in auschwitz already we didn't
know where we were i never heard of
auschwitz
we just saw people running around like
mad people
no hair and clothes with stripes
and i said to my father you know maybe
we are going to survive
look there are people running around
maybe they are workers
and my father said to me look my family
he said
i think we have arrived and there's one
thing i
i want to tell you whoever survives
you've got to go and work right away
sell your knowledge go to work
keep your sanity and keep the
principles that you have been taught
that was his last words i heard
and we came off we were so happy to
have some fresh air how long had the
trip taken
i don't know maybe an eternity maybe
only two days maybe only 24 hours
maybe just six hours i do not know but
it seemed an
eternity i remember
do you remember the boxcar do you
remember other people did you talk to
people
nobody talked nobody talked
did people cry we just looked at one
another
i remember i was full of life a young
girl and i said what's going to happen
to me
i'm just starting i'm just starting to
blossom i understood that
what's going to happen to me and i just
looked around
i didn't cry never
and i i think that
that also has strengthened my
my feeling toward the jewish people
because i saw them
as animals when you are
hungry you are like an animal because
that
pains you terribly and yet
they were not animals never
everything went fast they did not give
you a chance to think
or to contemplate where you are going
what you are going to do it
they brought us there to destroy
our bodies and soul i didn't get a
chance
sometimes that bothers me
i didn't get a chance to say goodbye to
my mother
i should have said something but i
didn't
because i thought we'll be together and
there were about 10 officers german
officers that a man said
go left go right go left go right and
all of a sudden
i found myself to the right with 5000
other women
everything happened so fast
i don't even know how i was walking and
i found myself in a big room
and they were already shaming off my my
head
and they gave me some clothes i remember
i had a long
black skirt with white stripe which was
at least
three sizes too large and a shocking
yellow
blouse no shoes that's all
and then they told us to go
to stand up
i think five women are four women stood
oh maybe two thousand women
and they took us to a block they called
it that was our housing
and i was in block 23
i didn't know what a concentration camp
was and i thought maybe this is it
or maybe in five days they will take us
to work
it's and i remember i was standing there
forever
after five or six days that we arrived
and somebody pats me on the shoulder and
i look at her
and i burst into crying it was my
sister-in-law
there were one million women they were
about 35 blocks
there were one million women looked all
alike no hair
some of them naked and my sister always
says hello to me
she says i'm in black 16 we arrived
three days ago
and i have my three sisters with me you
are going to come and live with us
of course what a question
and after three days i heard that black
23
has been sent to the crematorium
and from that day on i knew i'm a
survivor
i knew it no matter what is going to
happen to me
and no matter how much i'm going to
start or that will hit me or
whatever i am going to survive
and tell the story one day
i think the worst of auschwitz were two
things
hunger no work
we were lying in those banks
a whole day long and talking about our
past
that was and the humiliation of our
souls
that was the worst part of auschwitz
and in the evening
when you dared to go out and you saw the
flames of the crematorium
that was disastrous
the smell of the human flesh
which we didn't know it was we were
young kids
inexperienced
of such horror who is
experienced in such ways and
we smelled something we saw few people
commit suicide
run to the buyers they couldn't take it
anymore
auschwitz if i would like to describe it
i would say that is
that has not been there has not been
people did not invent an expression what
auschwitz was
it was hell on earth
and
the silence of auschwitz
was hell
the nights were hell
and the days somehow
he we got up at three o'clock in the
morning
and at four o'clock summer time of 43
when the sun came up
it was not like the sun i
swear to you it was not bright
it was always red to me it was always
black to me
it never said never
was life to me it was destruction
the sun was never beautiful
and when the moon was out
it meant only destruction
we almost forgot what life was all about
but
we are supposed to be the chosen people
i never believed in that
but maybe we are chosen
that we always stayed humanitarian even
there
took care of each other
i think we are chosen for that that we
didn't kill each other
i used to be so hungry
that i thought if a dog would pass by
i want to take the chair if i would have
seen the chair
it hurt me so that i wanted to run and
scream
and go mad just go mad
i was so hungry
and there was all my colleagues
prisoners and i would have never done
any harm to them
ever and i
don't i would be a fool to say it
it happened because i'm jewish and i'm
different by no means
but if you are chosen
we are chosen for that that we always
understand the underdog
and there's one episode that i would
like to tell you
i don't know how long we have been in
those box carts but it was
dark i still hear it they i still hear
the um
the teen time nobody said a word we were
just wondering where
are they going to take us one morning i
think it was morning or early afternoon
i don't know we arrived and that
the train stopped there for an hour
why we don't know and a
friend of mine said why don't you stand
up there was just
a little window with bars and see
i said i can't i don't have enough
energy to climb up
she says i'm going to sit down and i you
stand on my
shoulders and i did
and i looked out
and i saw paradise
the sun was bright and vivid
there was cleanliness all over it was a
station
somewhere in germany there were three or
four people there one woman was a child
nicely dressed up a child was crying
people people were people not animals
and i thought paradise must look like
this i have
i forgot already how normal people look
like
how they act how they speak how they
dress
i saw the sun in auschwitz i saw the sun
come up
because we have to get up four in the
morning venezuela was beautiful to me
never i know i never saw it shine
it was just the beginning of a horrible
day
and in the evening the end of what
and but here there was life
and i and i had such yearning i
still feel it in my bones i had such
yearning to live
to run to just run away and never come
back
to run to the end
but there is no way back i mean i
told the girls i said girls you have no
idea how beautiful the sun is and i saw
a baby was
crying and a woman was kissing that baby
is there such a thing as love
and my sister-in-law at this point
lost two children one was six years old
the mom was one-year-old
the boy's name was eli and the little
girls was named dina
and she knew she lost them and she
started to cry
terribly i'm not sorry i have ever said
it
anyhow
we left and about next day
a german officer came in and said who
can cook
so yes nobody wants to volunteer he said
i need two cooks
and my sister-in-law said how about
volunteering at least we won't starve
i said i'm scared i'm scared to
volunteer maybe that's
maybe they they're fooling us
he said i am serious i need two cooks
so we volunteered
and about three four hours later we
arrived to a towns arts fair
which had a big munition factory
and a sugar factory
and as soon as we arrived they put me to
the kitchen
that was very nice because there was
food there
and i cooked for
i think it was about 60 ss one day
i just have to laugh about it today how
compulsive the germans are
the factory was bombed and all the
windows
in the in that essence kitchen was uh
broken with would you believe that
within half an hour those windows were
fixed
they are so compulsive
and next the americans came and bombed
again but they always fixed it they
didn't leave
that it had to be they are that
compulsive
henry i just want to tell you about my
liberation which is a very beautiful
story
anyhow it was about 10 o'clock in the
morning we heard lots of
commotion all over tremendous
pressure all over the the gates were
closed
and i want to emphasize that south
sweden did not have only jewish
prisoners
we have been with lots of danish
and dutch prisoners and gypsies
and the gates were closed
and everybody was standing in the yard
like one man
and about 11 o'clock
we heard a tank
stopping at the gate and two shots fired
and the gates opened and as we ran
there was a white and a black american
standing side by side in the tank
that's the first time i saw a black man
i loved him for it all my life
and he's too direct maybe because he
understood
and the boss was running
he shot him i still didn't see him lying
there with his beautiful shiny boots
that i was shining an hour before
and i had no pity on him and we were
liberated
he said everybody goes and everybody
went
crazy crazy
and there was a milk factory
yeah not a factory but a walker dairy
a daddy and we went to the dairy
and we ate so much we all got sick
and i recalled the same afternoon
i sat down on a big stone and i said to
myself what's now
what's going to happen to us now we're
all free
are we really free where's the family
i'm a young person who had a sheltered
innocent life and what am i going to do
now
who's going to take care of me this just
came back like an echo to me
keep all your principles that you
brought from home
go and work sell your knowledge
i did i worked two weeks later i spoke
german and english
for some crazy reason
i took english in school in the
gymnasium
the third gymnast we are 13 years old
everybody took french and latin and i
wanted to take english
and my mother did not think it was
elegant enough you've got to learn
french
now i said i want to learn english why
i don't know i want to learn english
and i spoke english well enough
that i became an interpreter
german because my german was my second
mother tongue
in english and years later i've realized
that
maybe nothing has happened just by
accident maybe i had to learn english to
survive afterwards
so that i got a good job a respectable
job
that i had respect for myself and i did
what i
was supposed to do not sponge around
after i was liberated
but go and work and do something with
your life
and look ahead and i did
i'm among the very lucky ones because i
have met
a marvelous man that i live with 33
years
who loves me exactly
for what i am by knowing me very well
and loves me also for my all my
shortcomings
and i have three wonderful daughters and
we are very close
i think i have accomplished i'm proud of
myself that i accomplished a great deal
and of course my husband was
tremendously
uh instrumental in this this is infinite
patience and mostly
he's the most loyal person
that i have ever met the most loyal
and with love of course
love can do mere when i heard about
cambodia
i went to a depression
because the world has not learned
i felt guilty i'm living in a beautiful
home
with all the comforts
and i'm impotent i do nothing
it pains me terribly
the world has not learned
i don't kill your brother or sister
no matter what the reason is
i shared the guilt today i do
the guilt the guilt of the world
that we just sit and know nothing about
the cambodians
or the vietnamese
or what we hear about africa
nobody stands up and be counted
i don't consider myself a coward person
how many times i say why am i so busy
that i cannot be counted and i don't
stand up
i don't take a banner in wallingford
connecticut where i live and say
do something that the cambodians
in two years will not exist it's the
same thing
why don't i do something why am i so
busy or did i really forget everything
already am i that comfortable
that i don't want to leave why am i just
plain tired
i don't know i have no answer
but it pains me terribly
and i'm restless that's the truth
and my family knows it and they feel the
same way
but we are all engaged in our own
private lives and busy lives
and there's no time for it
and it's wrong i don't have the answer
i feel we should be the ones who stand
up
i don't
you